when people use the word perimeter in
everyday language they're talking about
the boundary of some area and when we
talk about perimeter in math we're
talking about a related idea but now
we're not just talking about the
boundary we're actually talking about
the length of the boundary how far do
you have to go around the boundary to
essentially go completely around the
figure completely go around the area so
let's look at this first triangle right
over here it has three sides that's why
it's a triangle so what's its perimeter
well here all the sides are the same so
the perimeter for this triangle is going
to be four plus four plus four and
whatever units this is if this is four
feet four feet and four feet there'd be
four feet plus four feet plus four feet
is equal to twelve feet now I encourage
you to now pause the video and figure
out the perimeters of these three
figures well it's the exact same idea we
would just add the lengths of the sides
so let's say that these distances and
their let's say they're in meters so
let's say that this is three meters and
this is also three meters as a rectangle
here so this is five meters this is also
five meters so what is the perimeter of
this rectangle going to be what is the
distance around the rectangle that
bounds this area well it's going to be
three plus five plus three plus five
which is equal to let's see that's 3
plus 3 is 6 plus five plus five is ten
so that is equal to 16 and if we're
saying these are all in meters these are
all in meters then it's going to be 16
meters now what about this Pentagon
let's say that each of these sides are 2
and I'll make up I'll make up a unit
here let's say there are two canoes two
canoes that's a new unit that I have a
new unit of distance that I have just
that I have just invented 2 - good news
- good news so what is the perimeter of
this Pentagon in good news well it's 2
plus 2 plus 2 plus 2 plus 2
Guu
or we're essentially taking one two
three four five
good news five five sides each have a
length of two good news so the perimeter
here we could add to repeatedly five
times or you could just say this is five
times two good news which is equal to
ten good news we're going to is a
completely made-up unit of length that I
just made up here we have a more
irregular polygon but same exact idea
how would you figure out its perimeter
well you just add up the lengths of its
sides and here I'll just do it Union
less I'll just assume that this is some
generic units and here the perimeter
will be one plus four plus two plus two
let me scroll over to the right a little
bit plus four plus six so what is this
going to be equal to 1 plus 4 is 5 plus
2 is 7 plus 2 is 9 plus 4 is 13 plus 6
is 19 so this figure has a perimeter of
19 and whatever units these distances
are actually given